[Applause]
[Music]
he won his job in a card game
he made a fortune from the financial
crisis
now he's warning the world the system
has to change
today we hear his story this shutdown is
creating the
greatest wealth heist the unemployment
rate has skyrocketed to its highest
level since the great depression
one of the largest corporate bailouts
with as few strings as possible
in american history welcome to the
another europe podcast with me
luke cooper and my co-host zoe williams
today we're joined by gary stevenson a
one-time city trader
he made a small fortune after the last
financial crisis
he successfully predicted that massive
state support to the financial system
would lead to a sharp inflation in asset
prices
so things like property stocks and
shares he was right
as the real world economy was barely
growing there were bull markets in wall
street and the city of london
you'd be forgiven for thinking the rich
got bailed out and the rest got sold out
gary retired from the city at the age of
and is now working as an economist
warning of the dangers of an economic
model with big returns for capital
low returns for labour after his
dazzling predictions
in the last financial crisis we'll be
asking him what he makes of the one
we're in
an even bigger economic collapse brought
about by the coronavirus pandemic
he also has a youtube channel gary's
economics where this podcast will also
be broadcast
he's got some great videos on there so
check it out as usual you can feed back
to us on the show
and feed in ideas on what you'd like us
to cover in the future
by emailing podcast another europe.org
you can also support the podcast by
leaving a rating or review
on your podcast platform an extended
version of this podcast is available to
members of another europe is possible
another europe is the home of the
european left in britain
by joining us you participate in our
movement building efforts to confront
injustice
oppose brexit disaster capitalism and
promote grassroots internationalism
to join support our work and gain access
to an extended version of this podcast
go to another europe.org forward slash
join
gary welcome to the show so tell us how
did you come to work as a trader
and what was it like but it's a funny
story actually um i actually won my
job trading in a card game when i was at
university
seems strange but i guess that's how
things happen sometimes
pre-financial crisis so i did my
undergrad at lsc london school of
economics
i don't know if you know the university
well but back then i'm guessing it's
still the same now
it was a bit of a mad place where a lot
of people were
borderline obsessed with getting jobs in
investment banking i remember i did my
first year i came back in second year
and just suddenly
everyone was applying for 20 30
different investment banks and
they're applying to all these different
divisions which all seem to have
acronym names ibd and m a or
nbs trading with cds and i really didn't
have any idea
what was going on for me it was quite
intimidating really because i
i don't really know anyone who comes to
that sort of background somewhere from
the year above
approached me and he was being paid by
citibank he he'd interned at seat bank
year before
and he was being paid to sort of do some
sort of talent scouting or something
he approached me and said oh we'll see
bank high as one trader year through a
maths game
um i heard you're pretty good at math so
maybe you should try that
so i thought why not i'll give it a go
so i turned up for this math competition
and it was kind of like it was a card
game like a sort of
supposed to be a trading style game you
buy and you sell
but it's hard it was a maths game so i
just ended that game and
i won the first round i got through to
the final and then i i studied it a lot
i went to the final and and i won that
and i got a job
i was completely mad yeah it was i was
working at dfs fluffing pillows at the
time in weekends and holidays
getting paid 45 pounds a day i don't
believe you quite believe that i'd
manage to get a job in this bizarre
fashion but
you know i won the game so it's great
and then i turned up
on the trading floor and i would have
just turned 20. i didn't really know
what's going on i was just offering to
buy people coffees and go get lunches
because
that's supposed to do with dfs but yeah
they they liked me i i didn't know
what's going on i don't know if you've
been on a trading field but it's a crazy
place
it's a huge huge huge room and
everyone's got like six or seven or even
nine
monitors and lots of shouting and lots
of noise and
yeah it took a bit of time to figure out
what was happening and what and what
year was that was that
that must have been before the financial
crash right so my internships would have
been in 2006 and 2007
because i started full time in 2008
right right right right so you basically
arrived just in time for this
unbelievable explosion which must have
been an experience
kind of in itself what um what was the
atmosphere like then did you
did did it seem really extreme or
because you'd had nothing to compare it
to
did it just seem like they were extreme
already i started full time in june 2008
right so the
the lima crisis was really soon after i
began lehman brothers staff arrived at
work in london this morning to be told
the bank had been put into
administration
stocks all around the world are tanking
because of the crisis on wall street
at the time i was a bit too
inexperienced really perhaps to
grasp the severity of it but you know
the traders let me know
they said like this is a massive massive
deal here sort of amounts of money being
made and lost were much much
bigger people were saying you know
citibank was bowed out by the american
government and
relatively quickly people realized that
the solvency of the bank
was under threat but also that there was
a sovereignty of basically every bank
under threat so right they knew it was
serious i knew it was serious without
really
knowing what serious meant if that makes
sense because i was so young
i was sort of taking it i could see the
emotion from
the traders at lse everyone's applying
for 20 30 banks it's kind of random what
banks you end up at you know so i had a
couple of friends who were at lehman
and just you know a couple years into
their career they suddenly lost their
jobs so
the kind of overall mood did it feel
like kind of in the eye of the crisis
did your colleagues seem like they
thought there was a big reckoning coming
with the way the system worked the way
the economic model worked the way
finance plugged into that
or were people not thinking in that kind
of
way on the trading floor traders are
very very
focused on making money they're not
really incentivized to think about
what's happening with the system
especially not on any sort of
moral or human sense they're very
incentivized to make predictions
so they might be thinking about for
example in the area where i worked
a big part of what we did and what we
were supposed to do was
predict the strength of the future
economy so obviously we have to do a lot
of that you know and there was a guy on
my team who
did really well which was just saying
this is going to be a disaster it's
going to last a really really long time
we're not going to get out of this for
ages and he made a lot of money on that
but
there's no you're not incentivized to
think about what that means really
you're very very heavily incentivized to
make
correct predictions so there's not
really much space for sort of sitting
and pondering
what does this mean for society and so
when the bailouts happened
surely at that moment like the whole
idea
that free market economics teaches us
that if a state provides resources to
the private sector
then that creates a moral hazard like
situation because if the risk
mechanism in the system just won't work
in the way that it's meant
to work because companies will know that
they're getting bailed out
at the end of the day was there no so
there's no conversation on the trading
floor
really about hang on a minute the whole
global financial system
has just been bailed out by the state
but things go on as normal
at the time the bailouts happened there
were a couple of people who
would mention this kind of thing on the
trading floor there's some huge places
there's hundreds of traders right and
i was on interest rates trading people
there would be very willing to say well
it was the credit traders
that blew the economy up so they sort of
they washed their hands of it so it was
nothing to do with us
kind of thing i think there were some
people who were aware like
you know it's people on this floor
who've made a lot of money
even if it wasn't people on my team
directly and then
when the losses come in the government's
taking them people were aware
that happened but a trading floor
is not really much of a place for
moralizing just just a couple of years
after 2008 we used to have once a year
we had
what was called a trading off site where
all the traders go to some place
somewhere and have like a weekend away
to get to know each other and this kind
of stuff and
just two years later in 2010 was it or
2011 at the beginning of the year
they took us away and they gave us this
massive speech saying look you're all
great traders we think you should
take more risk and they gave us these
little camo baseball hats we said on the
front
go big or go home and they said if
you're comfortable taking a risk in
in one million dollars why don't you
take it in 10 million
and the i mean this is clearly taking
advantage of
the system that is in place with
investment banks which runs all the way
through
as an individual trader if you make a
lot of money you'll be paid a lot of
money
but if you lose a lot of money you might
get fired but you won't
lose any money personally but the same
situation exists for your boss
and the same situation exists for his
boss and the same situation exists for
his boss so
there really is an incentive for traders
and
all really through that structure to
encourage greater risk taking
to the extent that even a couple years
after 2008 when
these banks collectively blew the world
up we would be encouraged just to take
much more risk go back and take much
more risk than you normally would
greed fraud dishonesty
and arrogance these are some of the
words
that best describe the reality of wall
street
today the predictions that you made a
lot of money on what were they
on were they on interest rates yeah so
the way interest rates are supposed to
work they're they're fixed by the
central bank so in this country the bank
of england
in the us the federal reserve and the
idea is actually relatively simple right
if they think if the central bank thinks
the economy is weak
and it's stimulating they cut the
interest rate and that's supposed to
make it cheaper for companies to borrow
and invest
cheaper for individuals to borrow and
spend it makes it less worthwhile saving
and it's supposed to encourage people
and companies to get out and spend and
get the economy
going if they think the economy is too
hot and they're worried about inflation
they do the opposite they raise rates
and that's supposed to encourage people
to
save so in 2008 all those interest rates
collapsed very very quickly to
zero or close to zero previously they've
been sort of like five percentage
depending on the country
you're looking at and at the time
because it was such a huge move in
interest rates
previously they'd move rates very small
amount like four and a half to four and
a quarter
five and three quarters to five and a
half suddenly everyone was cutting i
think the uk cut from five and a half to
zero point five
and every country was doing that
everyone expected there to be a really
rapid recovery based on these
huge moves and interest rates so my job
was to basically bet what will the
interest rate be in
two years time in three years time and
based on
basically will when will the economy
recover
if you go back and look at the history
of this it's really interesting because
the rates collapsed to zero in 2008 and
at the time everyone predicted
they'll go up in 2009 then when 2009
came
the economy was still weak those
predictions got pushed back to 2010. but
in 2010 it was 2011 2011 it was 2012.
in 2012 it was 2013. and even if you go
back last year
people were predicting rises for this
year so it's
it's really it's it's some it's it's
really phenomenal to think about it's as
if you turn on the weather forecast
and they were just predicting 37 degrees
and sunny every day
in london or if you watch the penalty
shooter and they all hit off for a
throw-in
they've just been wrong every single
year so my job was to bet will this
happen
and after seeing the first couple of
years of predicting a recovery that
didn't happen
i started to become i started to
question really the ideas i learned at
the university and
why is the recovery not happening what
is the problem and i developed these
theories that inequality is much more
important than most economists to
realize
which means that because we're not
addressing inequality the crisis
will be very very long term because
we're not fixing the underlying problem
essentially
so i basically bet that rates will stay
zero or close to zero for a very long
time
and they did is it right to say that if
you're
the one trader who's getting the
predictions right
and everyone else is getting the
predictions wrong
that means that you're going to make
more money is that a fair assumption
yeah yeah i mean the things have changed
a little bit since i was there
um but back then you
you were expected to make personally a
percentage of what you made for the bank
it was all a little bit murky because
there's no contractual obligation for
the bank to do that so at the end of the
year you kind of have to hope that they
actually
pay you which was sort of a strange
setup but yeah the idea is that you will
get paid
more personally if you make more for the
bank as you had this realization
did your politics change as you were
doing the economics
your personal politics and not at first
because
you know at the time i was just super
focused on
understanding the economy it's it's such
an interesting place
to work and to sort of be there
competitively making predictions
trying to make the right predictions i
was really just single-mindedly focused
on
try make the right prediction try and
make the right prediction now when i
first came to this
idea that i think inequality is much
much more important than
economists realize or what they teach at
university
at first i wasn't certain of that i was
quite confident because you know i've
been thinking about these ideas for a
couple of years but i wasn't certain
but i was confident enough to make a big
bet on it and then
yeah when it came back super successful
and it was phenomenally successful that
year when i did that 2011
i was the most profitable trader in the
bank globally that year on the back of
that
then when that came back at first i just
wanted to make sure i got paid
because this is a weird world and you
know they might just fire you instead of
paying you and it was a lot of money
that was on the line
but once that was done i sort of sat
back and i thought well that was
strange because i mean you might think
in a civilized society
if you have been paid a lot of money to
correctly predict that there's going to
be a long-term
economic crisis there might be some sort
of like escalation like
okay you should probably go and talk to
the government and explain what's going
to happen but
they just said all right that was great
we all made money do it again
it was only after it happened it had
been really successful that i started to
think
well that was strange if you're very
very good at making economic predictions
you can get paid a lot by bank but
there's not really many other places i
mean
that's why i'm here on this podcast
right to try and tell people right if
the government's listening give me a
shout i'll work for free i'll tell you
what's happening
i mean but just that story i mean the
story itself
is just extraordinary because of course
it's just
so true and so correct
that if you have something to contribute
to the structure of society that is hang
on a minute
inequality is unproductive to our
economy
the bank has made a massive amount of
cash
from that prediction you and then they
say okay fine
that's good work go away and do it again
and of course this prediction has really
a lot of social utility for the rest of
society
as you say in a civilized country and in
a civilized world
this would be hang on a minute we need
to have significant
macroeconomic change to redress the
imbalance between labor and capital
right
i mean what what happened was this sort
of problem sort of built up in me
over time eventually i i escalated to
management and i said you know i just
don't think i can do this anymore
because
i think you know my genuine predictions
at the time
were that the economy was going to be
really weak for a long time
and they still are they have been ever
since and the predictions have been very
successful ever since then
and you know after about six months
after that i went to management and said
yeah i think i need to take some time
out and figure out what i can do here
and then they they very strongly
encouraged me not to do that and then
about a year later i went back and said
look i i think i need to leave i think i
need to go and work for a charity
that's work on inequality because i just
don't think it's right me just sitting
here making money on
the world being terrible and um yeah
let's just i don't want to go in too
much detail on that but let's say the
bank made it very difficult for me to
make that decision
of finally leaving and uh talking
publicly about inequality so yes
it's a strange world we live in where if
you you can get paid
huge sums of money working for
investment banks betting the economy
will be terrible forever
but i mean after i went to oxford and to
do a master's degree and tried to tell
the professors and say look economy is
going to be terrible forever and they
just said well go read this 100 page
paper you know they weren't too
interesting
i think that's a lot of the journey but
i mean i should say for podcast
listeners
i mean you've written some stuff for
open democracy
that we will put in the podcast
description but we came across
you through a mutual friend who works
for another europe is possible alina
ravanava he's a momentum member
in tower hamlets so just at this stage
you know you must have in this journey
through citibank to oxford you ended up
thinking well hang on a minute
this guy jeremy corbyn momentum they've
actually got a point
i mean that's like a quite phenomenal
journey in quite a short space of time
it might seem like a big journey really
but
for me i think i don't view myself as a
hugely political person but you know my
life has been
devoted for 15 years now to the study of
economics and
i've been very successful doing that
i've made a lot of money doing that and
i think it's because i have understood
that inequality is phenomenally
important i think if you don't do
something about it
it's not just the moral issue here you
know it leads to low wages unaffordable
housing lower living conditions
and that's what i think
happens if you have very high inequality
and i don't think it's really understood
at university i think that's the reason
why i've been able to
beat the market year after year so since
i think that that's my economic view i
need to find a way
to get my voice out basically so i've
been looking for the last few years
basically
just spaces where i can speak about
inequality and its relevance to
economics so i've been looking through
loads of different channels i
volunteered at new economics foundation
for a bit working with a guy called
james midway
when momentum popped up but these guys
were talking a lot about inequality
and i thought maybe here's a place where
i can get a bit of a voice
to be honest i've been looking all over
the place you know i wrote for the daily
express
last week yeah it might seem like a long
journey to be honest but you know
i look i learned about economics at lsu
and in the banking sector and
the way i see it is if we don't do
something about inequality
the economy is going to be in a really
really bad way so
you know for me it's not a political
issue do you want an economic disaster
or don't you
before we get back to the podcast with
gary and his truly amazing story
a quick shout out for a new series of
podcasts i've made for the lse
about the causes of war and conflict in
the 21st century
across six episodes we dig deeper into
the ideas and theory you need to make
sense of society's experiencing
intractable conflict and organized
violence
we investigate the causes of conflict in
the horn of africa central africa and
the middle east
expose the networks of dark money
fueling conflict
and uncover the positive stories of
democratic civil society resistance
promoting peace and social justice you
can find them
by searching for conflict zone from the
lse
wherever you get your podcasts from
so to move on to that impending disaster
or the disaster we're already in
can you describe how the economic
choices made in the financial crash
produced a sharp increase in global
inequality yeah so when we go back to
this is what economists might call a
demand crisis right which is worth just
talking about just a little bit
it's a crisis that happens when suddenly
people stop spending
and that's an interesting crisis because
i think when people think about
economics
they tend to think about the production
side of things they think oh we've got a
problem because we're not producing
enough
but 2008 and in many ways also this
crisis now
is coming about because people suddenly
stop spending and that creates a problem
because if people stop spending
then companies let off workers they
don't invest they don't grow
and lots of people lose their jobs and
we get high unemployment people can't
pay their bills so
in that sense that crisis and this
crisis is now quite similar now
modern mainstream economic thinking like
you would get at university will
basically tell you there's two things
you can do in this kind of situation
one is what they'll call fiscal policy
which is basically governments just come
in and directly spend
so the problem with the economy is not
enough spending so the government comes
in they spend themselves
and you know it could be on anything
really but you know obviously there's a
lot of talk this time of a green new
deal or you know
necessary investments and infrastructure
this kind of thing but the idea is we
don't have enough spending in the
economy
so the government comes in and spends
that creates the spending
that creates the jobs that prevents
unemployment from going up
uh that's fiscal policy that's one way
to deal with it and in 2008
a decision was kind of made over the
longer term especially by the
conservative
it was a coalition government after 2010
not to really go for a lot of aggressive
fiscal support not to go for a lot of
government support
so that meant instead we went for the
other method of supporting which is
what we call monetary policy monetary
stimulus and
in this mode of supporting an economy
the central bank so in this country the
bank of england
prints a lot of money i think people get
confused about that sometimes but you
just need to understand the central bank
is allowed to create new money
electronically
and then they lend that into the system
now this is a more interesting way of
stimulating an economy
because it doesn't directly create
spending it doesn't directly create
demand
the people who get lent the money need
to spend it so
what happened in 2008 largely the
central bank lends loads of money to the
commercial banks and then the commercial
banks need to lend it on
but of course the people who can most
easily borrow money from commercial
banks
are big investment funds or companies or
richer individuals
and what happened in 2008 was because
there wasn't much
space for growth because there wasn't
much spending rich individuals and
investment corporations they borrowed
this
money and rather than investing they
just bought existing assets
so if you go back and look at 2008 you
can see
even though the economy was really weak
relatively quickly after the crisis
asset prices started roaring upwards so
the first one was gold gold
started flying and you might have seen
just overnight last night gold hit a new
all-time historic high
so it's happening again now first gold
started going up
then relatively quickly stocks started
going up and then after a short delay
house prices started going up
so what happened in 2008 was because
they chose just to go with full-on
monetary policy print new money
lend it into the economy it tended to
benefit rich people
firstly because they could borrow the
money and secondly because they use that
to push asset prices up
and when asset prices go up who does
that benefit well of course that
benefits the people who own
assets which is rich people again so the
focus on
monetary policy without any direct
government intervention led to a huge
increase
in inequality because of greater access
to money for rich people and also
huge increases in asset prices which are
owned by rich people
what would need to happen in society for
so capitalists aren't investing
productively
they're investing in speculation in
existing assets
what would actually need to happen in
order to get those capitalists
to invest in things like jobs production
manufacturing capacity a green
industrial revolution
a green new deal it's a tricky one
really because
the reason that the rich are not really
investing in new production at the
moment is because the demand isn't there
so it's it's a difficult situation how
do you encourage these guys
i mean basically there's two questions
within your question one is how do you
get them to invest in good things
as opposed to potentially socially
harmful things but the second question
is how do you get them to invest at all
because at the moment you know like i
said gold is a record all-time historic
high
rich people buying gold doesn't do much
for the economy obviously
lots of stocks are at all-time highs as
well so
it's difficult to encourage the rich to
invest because ultimately
what they're going to want to invest in
is what's profitable i think you
probably do need to create the demand
directly somehow
and i think that's that's difficult to
do without direct some form of direct
government intervention
so there's two ways you can get
the rich to invest you can either
directly incentivize them or you can
provide the customers
but i think the problem is because we
don't have the spending
we're not going to get the investment
from the rich so it's a little bit it's
a little bit of chicken and egg in the
sense you need to get the spending first
of all
but it's very difficult to get the
spending when the rich have all the
money
is there an argument then that the
better way for a central bank to use
those
mechanisms it has is just a kind of
helicopter money scheme where instead of
putting it's the currency it's created
into the hands of the
commercial banking sector it just puts
them into everybody's bank account i
mean i know they were talking about that
at the beginning of the corona virus
crisis
or rather the government weren't but
people were i mean it's interesting to
say that because
i mean this crisis is not identical to
the last crisis and what has happened so
far
it is actually quite similar to what you
just said essentially
um previously most of the newly printed
money that the central bank created
most of it went into the banking system
first of all some went directly to
governments but
this time a huge amount has gone
to the government essentially and the
government has used a lot of that money
to support
for example things like the furlough
scheme and the self-employment scheme
which means that ultimately the newly
printed money
has gone in to the bank accounts of
people who are struggling in this crisis
so
in some sense especially because of the
usage of the furlough scheme
the policy response has been much more
egalitarian in a sense be much more
supportive of ordinary people
and what that has meant is interestingly
so far in this crisis
even though the depths of it if you look
at falls in gdp
much sharper than 2008 actually most
people have not felt anything like the
kind of economic pain that was felt like
in 2008 yet but what i'm really
concerned about is that
the furlough scheme firms have to start
contributing to keep works on furlough
from the end of this month which is in
just a few days now
and a lot of workers are going to be
left off so i'm worried that
we've done really well to sort of stave
off the worst human disaster so far in
this crisis so far
but it seems like we're just about to
stop doing that and we're just going to
let the human
disaster come in terms of the
government's wider response to this
crisis
what do you think that it has been
far-sighted in you know in the sense
that they were putting money into
people's bank accounts rather than into
the
bank accounts of commercial banks in the
first instance or do you think that was
just a kind of knee-jerk
what we're going to do which and
then and the
kind of true nature of their response is
coming out now
they had to do it they had they had to
do they had to do it
if they had not have done that the it
would have been a humanitarian disaster
in this country
if they had not brought in a furlough
scheme it would have been a humanitarian
it would have been
it would have been unthinkable how bad
it would have been had they not done
that so
as much as it's great that they did do
it i don't want to congratulate them too
much for doing it because every western
country did it because they had to do it
without doing that it would have been
inevitably a disaster so
i can't say that they're noble people
all i can say is they're not complete
idiots because they had to do that right
they absolutely had to do that i mean
looking at it unfold
the bbc came out today saying it might
take four years for the economy to
recover
it feels like that's incredibly
optimistic from where i'm sitting but
obviously i'm not i've never made my
fortune doing economic predictions
they'll be talking about gdp as a whole
right gdp could recover in four years
but i mean gdp took its time to recover
after 2008
and it did eventually recover but by the
time it recovered
where were house prices compared to
wages so
the gdp recovers but the inequality
crisis remained
and ordinary people felt the effects of
that and i think
those are the mistakes that we're going
to repeat here so i think the photo
scheme was
phenomenal absolutely essential and
vital
but i've this i wrote about my open
democracy cycles and i put my
video up on youtube gary's economics
describing what happens to this money
how it's absolutely essential that it
comes in
but ultimately it's filtering up to
higher income people and it's increasing
inequality just like rapid in 2008
and we're already starting to see the
effect on asset markets the gold price
the stock prices
there's a lot of news coming in now that
looks like house prices are moving
upwards with we're seeing the exact same
things again which is
yes the absolute worst of the
humanitarian disaster seem to be being
prevented we're not
hopefully we're not going to have
another great depression start absolute
collapse
but we're paying for that with increased
inequality and i predict we'll see
another big increase in house prices
like we saw last time
you have to ask what that's going to do
you know if house prices double again
which is eventually what happened in
london after the 2008 crisis
what does that mean for families that
don't own housing now it basically means
they will never ever own housing you're
basically telling
you know the 50 of the lowest wealth
people
you guys lost capitalism you will never
get a house you know
that that is so you might get a gdp
recovery
but it will be at the cost of basically
canceling the bottom half of society and
saying these guys will never own housing
ending social mobility so i think we
really need
when we talk about being farsighted we
need to look at what's happening with
inequality
because if we make if we keep making the
same mistake of just allowing inequality
to ratchet up and up and up and up
then it's going to be disaster for a lot
of people he's not a conventional
economist and i'm not even sure if he's
taught on
university economics degrees but he had
the very successful book capital in the
21st century thomas piketty
and he he argues that when returns on
capital are high so the asset prices
that you're talking about
and returns on wages are really low and
depressed
then the inevitable result is just
growing
inequality you've come to the conclusion
from the root
you've described but you do you
basically endorsing
what pikaty is saying and how he's
analyzing things
i've read piketty's book it's a very
very big book
one picket you brought that bouquet was
great because i've been thinking about
inequality a lot
in the previous years coming up i think
that book came out in 2012 maybe 2013.
what that did was it really brought
inequality onto the agenda
up until then really i mean like i said
i've been five years university studying
economics inequalities hardly mentioned
at all so up until pikay brought that
book out it wasn't really in them
in the eyes of economies at all and it
really brought it into the eyes of
economy so i think he's done a really
great service in doing that in terms of
the analysis itself
it's not really the same kind of thing
i'm thinking there's actually a few guys
now
some economists called miyan and sufi
working with a guy called straub
that are really looking at this idea
that when inequality gets very large
it creates a situation where all of the
income is going to the rich and they've
got nothing
on which to spend it so they end up
either lending it back to the poor
or buying houses from the middle class
and it means that inequality leads to
greater inequality
because if all the money goes to the
rich they use that money to buy houses
that pushes house prices up which means
maybe ordinary people who might not be
too well off they think well i'm going
to sell my house because i could have a
really good life
and the houses transfer up i think we're
really seeing that in society now
you're seeing that as the roots get
richer they generate huge amounts of
income from their wealth
they use that wealth to buy the rest of
the wealth which means that
inequality goes up even more so these
guys
who are looking at this kind of stuff
now these guys mian and sufi and straub
that's the kind of analysis i like more
i was kind of wondering if
if we're talking about what we should be
campaigning for what economic
vision the opposition should be building
because it does seem to be a
time they did do that are we are we
saying in the first instance
that you have to stop using gdp as a
measure because i've actually never
heard anybody articulate so strongly
what you just said in terms of how how
ineffective a measure of a nation's
wealth it is
so often people say gdp is no good to
measure because it doesn't measure
well-being
but actually what's wrong with gdp is
that it measures
when you aggregate with the wealth of a
nation you completely erase the
the story of the people who don't hold
it so should you in the first instance
be saying gdp is no longer our thing and
not because we want to measure happiness
instead
yeah it's a good question i really
remember
during the the brexit debates before the
brexit i don't know if it was question
time there was some conservative mp it
might have been george osborne
on there and it he was talking about how
gdp has gone up and up and up and
some i think it was a woman in the crowd
stood up and she shouted out that's your
gdp
and i thought good on you because she's
i'm guessing she's not a professional
economist
but she's realized something i think a
lot of economists probably should
realize the problem is
personally i think from my experience at
universities a big problem with
economics is
at the big universities almost everyone
in the department is from a wealthy
background
they don't realize that the economy is
very different for rich people
as it is from ordinary people and as gdp
is going up and up and up i think a lot
of people are very aware that
lives maybe haven't gotten better for a
lot of people maybe a lot of people my
generation younger than me
might feel that their parents lives were
easier economically than theirs
even though gdp goes up and up and up so
i wouldn't say completely throw gdp out
like it's a completely useless measure
of course it is a useful measure but if
gdp is going up and at the same time
loads and loads of people are saying my
life's getting worse
listen to that and give it a thought
that maybe something's really happening
because
we've got a big problem in economics
that very few people with more than any
background
are getting into these university
departments anymore so if ordinary
people are coming to you and saying no
things are not good for us
you have to listen to them i think so
don't completely acknowledge gdp
but listen also to ordinary people and
what they're saying and if they say
we're not happy with what's happening in
the economy ask them why and
answer those questions because like i
said the last two years i did a masters
at oxford
and i found that the faculty there were
unbelievably disconnected from what was
happening in the real world and
i spoke to one of the professors i said
to him you know he asked me why are you
so unhappy in the lectures and i said
because you're not talking about what's
really happening
why don't you talk about the housing
crisis and he said to me
well because the housing crisis is only
in london and i said well the housing
crisis is only in london because there's
no jobs outside of london
and he said to me yes there are jobs
outside of london i've got a job
this guy's an economics professor at
oxford university
you know if you're going to tell like
some guy who's lost his job in a factory
in wigan you're going to say
well actually there's a vacancy at
oxford for an economic suppressor why
don't you go and apply for that like
it's it's boggles the mind how you know
these guys standing there with capes and
bow ties tell him everything's fine
you're like
honestly it's it's a massive it's a
massive massive massive problem a lack
of representation
of people from ordinary financial
positions
in these in the world of economics it
has to be fixed because in the end
you end up with a load of rich people
saying everything's great because for
them it's great
we have to fix that and you know part of
that is not just fixating on one measure
i mean the idea that you could
reduce boil down the whole economy to a
number 269 billion
or something like this it is absurd
isn't it and the fact that so many
economists have sold themselves to that
perhaps illustrates maybe how
short-sighted they're being
yeah so we've covered really brilliantly
the role that if you only look at it in
terms of monetary
policy then that's a really big factor
in creating
this high inequality system could we now
like come on to talk about what the
alternative
is and what the government should be
doing because presumably this means
and i think it was implied by what you
said earlier
that the government should be engaging
in direct
job creation in response to the crisis
because you're arguing well look we
shouldn't really expect
the private sector and the very wealthy
with all the capital to be investing
productively at the moment it's going to
be that the government will need
to take up the slack say is that right
and if it's right how does the
government pay for it
yeah what i would say first of all is
i've spoken quite negatively about
monetary policy
i just want to be clear i'm not against
the monetary expansion i don't think the
monetary expansion is a bad thing in and
of itself you know if you go back and
look at the great depression
back then they didn't expand the
monetary supply and it was it was
horrendous disaster and
probably the money that they've pumped
into their system both now and in 2008
probably did prevent the kind of
terrible humanitarian disaster that we
saw
back in the great depression but it led
to this huge increase in inequality
and that huge increase in inequality has
led to long-term stagnation
so i don't want to say i'm opposed to
monetary policy because i'm not
but we need to then address this
inequality that has been caused
because once you then have huge levels
of inequality then you have the
situation where all of the income and
all of the wealth is being held by very
rich people
and what we know about very rich people
is they don't spend a lot of money
comparative to how much money they have
so once all the money gets captured by
the richest
you end up with this very low demand
economy because you know it doesn't
matter how
much money bill gates has if he's a
million times richer than an ordinary
person
he's probably more than that times
richer he's not gonna
he's not gonna eat three million meals a
day he's not gonna spend enough money to
drive the economy
so we need to address this inequality
question so what i would say is
look throw the money in because it's
helping it's working that has
managed us to get so far in this current
crisis without a disaster
but you have to address this inequality
you have to find a way to address this
inequality
and that's why what i've been
campaigning for up till now in this
crisis has been a wealth tax
and when i say wealth tax i want to make
it clear i'm not talking about
you know doctors and lawyers or nurses
and teachers who might be earning higher
than average
i'm talking about people who own huge
amounts of wealth
people who maybe have net wealth of over
5 million 10 million this kind of money
these guys who are gonna make huge
amounts of money in this crisis
just like they did in the last crisis we
need to find ways to make these guys
contribute because as it is
they just get richer and richer every
year they suck the wealth out of the
middle class and you can see the
shrinking homeownership rates in this
country
that that wealth is not disappearing
it's going up to the very very riches
so i think it's really important that we
think think about how can we address
this inequality
going forward and for me that has to be
looking at the tax system
my concern is that when we come out of
this people are going to look at how can
we raise revenues
and if you look at how to raise revenues
you're always going to find it's easier
to tax the middle class
and the poor because these guys can't
defend themselves it's difficult to tax
the rich
but if we do that we're not going to fix
inequality and we're going to end up
with greater inequality over the long
term
which is going to lead us to more and
more long-term economic stagnation
so what i'm pushing for at the moment is
a wealth tax on very wealthy individuals
it's not going to be easy to do it needs
to be well planned and well designed
and it might even require some degree of
international cooperation
now that's not going to be easy but
right now every single country in the
world has the same problem
so this is an unbelievable opportunity
for us to fix this problem and if we
don't fix it
it's just going to get worse inequality
will get bigger and bigger house prices
will go up and up and up
and accumulating any sort of financial
stability will become increasingly
impossible for ordinary people
so what i'm pushing for at the moment is
a wealth tax it's not going to be quick
it's not going to be easy but it's i
think it's vital if you want to avoid
long-term economic stagnation i'm
talking about decades
that concludes this episode for those
listening on the podcast
platforms this podcast was produced as
part of a collaboration
with the friedrich herbert stifton for
more information on their work on
building progressive dialogues between
germany and britain
go to fes hyphen london.org
an extended version of this podcast is
available to members of another europe
as possible
in this week's extra time we asked gary
for his thoughts on whether the system
of global inequality
is driving support for political
nationalism
another europe is the home of the
european left in britain
to join our people-powered movement go
to anothereurope.org
forward slash join
[Music]
you've said that your game is economic
predictions not political ones
so with that massive caveat aside can i
take the liberty of asking you
whether you think that there's a link
between global inequality and the
economic choices
made since 2008 and the type of politics
we've got since 2008 which with a few
exceptions
here and there does seem to see across
the globe and it
not just in europe the rise of quite
nasty strong man and they are men
ethnic nationalists from modi in india
that we did a podcast on
to trump in the united states and you
know trump to use trump as an example i
mean he actually
i would say didn't answer
the conditions that you're talking about
he certainly hasn't proposed anything
that would really address
a global economic inequality and far
from a wealth tax has cut
a huge tax cuts for the rich but
nonetheless in terms of the
political language he used to take power
back in 2016 it was very very
strongly motivated and involved to this
kind of
critique of globalization a system that
isn't working for people
and it seems that that argument has been
occupied
by the far right globally generally
and not the left so is there a link
between this rise of nationalism and
authoritarianism and those economic
choices yeah that's a good question
i mean i'll stress before i answer that
that obviously economics my own
expertise
so politics of course i've got opinions
like everyone but you know take what i
say with a pinch of salt
what i'll say is i come from quite a
poor background and
i think that people that i grew up with
they feel that things are not getting
better
they feel things are getting more
difficult and i think they feel ignored
i think they feel that nobody's
listening nobody's addressing
what's happening to them you know i
think they just feel like
it doesn't matter who they vote for
things don't get
better you know that that's that's the
sense that i get you know from
from people i grew up with people in my
family people i speak to
i i think a lot of that you know i'm
sure it's not 100 economic but i think a
lot of that is economic
people just feel you know like you know
my dad he never went to university you
know he just worked for the post office
his whole life but he's got a house he
raised
three kids on that you know we never had
a lot of money but
we were we were secure nowadays you'd
struggle to live
on you know just going to get a job at a
post office you know
with just one parent working so i think
people feel that things are not getting
better for them
and i think people feel that mainstream
politicians are not answering that
question you know i think they've
they've lost faith in politicians and
you know i mean i i've lost faith in
politicians i've lost faith in
economists to be honest you know
i mean people also just like i said
economists have been predicting
the recession would end next year for 12
years you know
people hear that they get the idea that
the people in charge have got no idea
what's going on
so if that's what everybody thinks then
if some new guy turns up and says that
i'm one of you
i'm with you guys i'll lead you out of
this you know
and he goes and have a as a point in the
pub with them
they'll be down because you know they
these guys need help and they're not
getting it and they feel that they don't
listen to
so you know like i said i'm not a
political expert you know
but i think the economic situation for a
lot of people is not good they can't get
financial security
it's not getting better they want
answers and
you know if the mainstream political
parties are not able to offer it
then they'll look for alternatives so i
think all of us
you know especially if we're from more
privileged financial situations i don't
come from that background but i know i'm
in that situation now
we need to take it upon ourselves to
engage with people who are not as
financially secure
and ask them why are you unhappy what's
wrong you know we need to bring them
into the political process because if we
don't
then they're easy game for anyone who
turns up you know and i think that's a
little bit what we're seeing
yeah i completely agree one of the
research projects we do at the lsc has
been on brexit
and quote unquote the left behind places
in britain
i mean interestingly enough where you
grew up tower hamlets is not
classic center of the stereotype
of the brexit vote of course you know
it's a deprived area
but your stereotypical brexit voting
area is somewhere like mansfield and
there
you find a really strong sense that
we're not being listened to
that the system isn't working for us
that it in terms of its economic profile
it tends to have very low wages
but fairly reasonably high levels of
home ownership
and low house prices house prices being
obviously as you would argue
a proxy for whether people want to live
there a proxy for demand right
so you get this profile of quite middle
of the road
towns and there i guess it leads me on
to an economics question because one of
the things that
you see in mansfield is the the whole
economy is structured around these
horrendous warehouses
sports direct has won infamously where
the labor
market conditions and labor rights are
just really poor
so one of the things that we've
emphasized on in this discussion so far
is the role of the state in raising
and re in delivering redistribution i
suppose there's another
way that it could be done and i guess
this is the question it would be raising
workers rights giving workers more
rights
more access to trade union
representation
stronger trade unions that presumably is
another way
of ensuring that labour has more of a
stake
in this system than it does at the
moment vis-a-vis capital
yeah i think this is these are all
important things to do you know you need
to give people
ordinary working people more power but
obviously my focus is always on
wealth distribution and wealth
inequality so as much as you need to
give these people
more organizational power i think you
also need they also need to get more
wealth and more money
and i don't think we can do that unless
we extract some demand from the rich i
mean
when i think about these areas like
mansfield i've never been to manchester
so but i'll put this on my website um
when i talk about the effects of
inequality on an economy and my website
my website is wealtheconomics.org
i talk about if you have a very unequal
economy then all of the wealth is held
by a small group
of course all of the jobs are going to
be where those people are and if you
look at the places
where housing is expensive now it's not
just
big cities like london it's also little
cities like oxford
and cambridge and ski villages but
what do these places have in common it's
where rich people spend their time
the place where rich people study are
expensive the place where rich people go
on holiday are expensive
because if you give all of the money to
rich people then ordinary people can
only get a job
if they're near the rich people if they
can serve the rich people somehow so it
obviously leads to a situation
where you gut the rest of the country
because you know rich people
they probably don't spend time in
mansfield nothing against mansfield but
they probably don't right and you know
if you don't redistribute wealth
then you will have a very geographically
concentrated economy if you concentrate
the wealth you will concentrate the
activity geographically as well
so i'm not an expert on workers rights
and unions so i don't want to
say too much on lots of people i'm sure
have more informed opinions than me but
what i want to say is
it's important that we protect the
wealth of people as well
their ability to own assets the ability
to own houses because
people are losing that right now and i
don't want to lose sight of that and if
we have a more equal distribution
then the people in mansfield can work
for each other and they can pay each
other and they can get good wages like
that
but if we give all the money to you know
100 families in london it's always going
to be difficult for them people
in in all the rest of the country to
find good work
[Music]
you